Let's look at the answer
to our cache tag quiz.
The cache tag always contains
the entire address of the first byte.
We know this is not true.
The address that we supply to the cache
on an access contains the offset.
And the block number.
We have seen that the tag only needs
to contain the block number part,
not the offset.
The block always begins
at an aligned address, so
the first part of the block
actually always has zero here.
So there is no need to
store those zeroes.
In the cache as a tag.
The tag only needs to give us the bits
that we need to identify the block,
the bits that we know are always
zero are not necessary.
So this is definitely not true.
It contains at least one
bit from the block offset.
Again this is not true.
We need only the bits that
tell us which block we have.
The block offset tells us where
are we within a particular block, so
these bits are never necessary.
That also means that this is not true.
However, the tag does contain at
least one bit from the block number.
We have seen in our example
that the entire block number
can be a tag in that particular cache.
In general,
it might be fewer than all of the bits,
but there is a least one of them.
So, this is the only correct answer.